I have a very distinct memory of like
being 10 years old and I tried to talk
to other kids my age but it did not go I
like started making animal noises I
[Music]
don't know that you can say like one
it's different for everyone personally
for me like I always talk about my
parents so it was literally school at
home home schooling is where your house
is your school really depends on what
you want to learn and how you want to
learn it
yes yeah I think even if you don't know
that you're awkward a lot of times
homeschool people end up being very you
are yeah I think it depends cuz like you
don't seem awkward I'm awkward
like I don't know if that's because I
was home-schooled or just because I'm
not of course
definitely yeah oh my god homeschooling
is really good because it allows kids to
learn at their own pace
I had learning disabilities and I just
needed a little extra time to catch up
every day is a field trip let's go to a
museum or let's go to the movies oh I
went to a cadaver lab don't lots people
do that probably yeah no we didn't do
the dissect no we did look at a body
that was dissected and they showed us
like a brain and they showed us some
testicles and they showed us like layers
of fat to show like what fat looks like
on the inside that freaked me out
[Music]
because there's so much freedom there is
sometimes more of an opportunity for it
to go wrong basically my parents aren't
great at math they don't who needs him I
didn't have any friends so I was like 14
daddy different out like 19 now like way
older home schoolers definitely sleep
longer than the public schoolers depends
what dope activity my mom or dad had
planned for us my home schooling was not
like most regular home schoolers because
I grew up Muslim we had a more
structural schedule you had a week up at
5:00 for your prayer yeah got a week off
for prayer and then after prayer then
you got you gotta make sure you have
breakfast or 7:00 and then we did
martial art after meditation time I was
never lonely
there were plenty of kids in my
neighborhood there were plenty of other
homeschool families that I knew I
wouldn't say that makes you lonely but I
would say it makes you more of a loner
[Music]
I wouldn't say homeschoolers are any
smarter than public or private or
whatever home schoolers are typically
really passionate about like a smaller
number of things and they're really good
at those things I would say on book
smart so we were smarter in the aspect
of being an adult I was home-schooled
all the way up until I started college
and I took like the SATs just like
anyone else or like a really good
entrance I hey bribery I didn't find
success by going to college I just found
it doing my own thing my parents are
very anti-establishment anti-government
they wanted to teach us what they wanted
to teach us without being told like this
is what your kid's gonna learn they
can't depend on like what your learning
pace is where you're like cultural or
like religious beliefs are or if you
just don't like the schools in your area
honestly most of the time it's just
because your parents wanted you to learn
things at home and learn things a
different way home schoolers are super
yeah
[Music]